hey guys what's up this is andrew for
10senses.com so in this video i will
quickly go with you through yesterday's
press action on amc uh we will discuss
the synthetic short the regular short we
are gonna have a look at the potential
next quizzes that can come on different
stocks so i'm going to show you how to
use my cool spreadsheet
and we also gonna discuss uh what kind
of targets we are having for amc for the
coming squeeze that might be coming in
september
we also gonna discuss how to
ride this wave at best so let's get into
[Music]
it okay so first thing yesterday's price
action on amc quickly so here once again
we have everything looking very good for
a massive move up
so we are trying to understand
how this
could be forming so my guess is that
it's gonna be five waves so one two
three four five so for now we are inside
the third wave here in yellow and we
need to identify five waves as well here
for now as you can see guys we have one
wave then correction and then here one
two so i never have five waves one two
three so for now we still don't see this
uh five waves that we need to see to
confirm we are in a new trend that is
going higher so for now in this in
inside the third wave i have one two
three
four
and i expect the fifth but the fifth
needs to come very quickly for this
scenario to be valid
because otherwise we're going to lose
momentum on the daily for now the
momentum is still going higher now is it
fine to have a retracement to the 4d
level so for to know that we're going to
measure this this potential third wave
all right so one
two three so only this one and usually
the false wave corrects the 38.2
and we can see that here the 38.2 was
around 33. so we are correcting
a bit deep to me
i mean according to elliot wave and
fibonacci theory uh but this is
acceptable i've seen many times false
wave going to be 61.8 retracement which
is 40.5 so it's fine but below that it's
not looking good i mean it's not looking
like this scenario is happening right
now so maybe it's going to be delayed so
what we need to see today for friday we
need to see a strong reaction
you know at the the worst case to the
8.6 you know the the 17.6 retracement
which is also a support so i mean do
those kind of access could be tolerated
but it's not good it's already weakening
a lot to move up so what i want to see
is a strong move up
uh to the 65 level why 65 because we are
going to use fib extensions from one to
three we applied to the bottom of the
force and we get 66 roughly so we know
we have a resistance here so it would
make sense that we go to the 65 level
then let me show you quickly how i
actually used fibs before because some
of you were asking me so here basically
once you have one plus three this is
when you can actually use fib uh
projections because they are very
efficient to know the target for the
fifths but before having one plus three
it is actually uh not that useful to me
to use the projections here you can see
that oneplus 3 in this move-up that was
started in may 21 was had fib projection
1.618 to the 70 level roughly this is
where we went so this is how i use fibs
but before having one plus three it's
very tough to do so here i have maybe
one plus three that's why i suppose
we're gonna go here
but once we're gonna have this one plus
three this is gonna be easy guys okay so
we're gonna have then here a retracement
probably
close to uh you know this kind of level
something like this
so it depends where it's gonna be the
third wave but this is how i'm gonna try
to guess the uh top of the fifth
so
what you guys can do because i know that
some of you you will just hold forever
that's very good but i know that some of
you are asking me how to ride this wave
at best so what i would do i would not
try to get uh the top of the third so
the yellow fifths because it's a bit
tricky to sell here and you know
re-enter here because this might be very
quick and very shallow i mean we don't
have enough information here to start
taking profits but once we get one plus
three
then we correct we're gonna correct the
force and here we're gonna have a lot of
information so basically for now the
best thing to do is just to hold and see
how high we can go depending on how high
we go and how deep we pull back
then we're gonna have a lot of
information about this level that is
gonna be the top of the fifth and here
it would be to me very it would make a
lot of sense to at least take some
profits for those who want to take
profits and to have the opportunity to
reload lower for a next quiz because
what is possible is that we get this
squeezes happening you know every three
months for example because my guess is
that for now you know the dtc
let me show you that the dtc is not uh
so this is jamie bam let's have a look
at mc i'm going to show you guys some
very very cool stuff on this spreadsheet
so bam
i
created my environment to have all the
information very quickly now so you're
gonna see how powerful the spreadsheet
is so for amc you can see that the dtc
is 1.4 all right so the
synthetic shot right now is eight
percent it can go up to twenty so we
have some upside gamma thanks to the 145
strike hold so this is very good very
bullish the regular shot is 16.7 so the
short is 25 so the gtc is only 1.4 guys
so basically shorts have a lot of time
to buy back the positions here they are
not in a rush for now so what i want to
see before
kind of being in a situation where we
can reach some crazy insane prices i
don't know some of you talk about 500
5000 even why not why not but not with
the dtc at 1.4 this won't happen i don't
think so so we need to wait for this to
grow and of course i know what you guys
gonna tell me and this is true i don't
take here into account the naked shorts
because i don't know how many there are
but imagine there is like there are
three times this which is a fair
assumption
okay
so we still have only four dtc so it's
still not enough to uh create i mean
some insane moves we would need to be
around 10 like we used to be in gen for
this moves to happen so i'm gonna keep
monitoring this so for now what i can
tell you is that uh once we have the top
of the third and the bottom of the force
we're gonna have some very good
information about where the fifth wave
might be going and this would be an
opportunity to maybe you know
exit and re-enter later
just uh saying that because i know that
some of you are asking me this and and i
know it's a touchy subject on amc but i
said that i'm gonna give my opinion
about that so this is my humble opinion
then
look guys what we can do here and by the
way i want to take the opportunity in
this video to make a big thank you to
jeff stockswinger so this guy here he
saw my video yesterday where i was using
this spreadsheet and he got of course uh
very amazed by the power of this
spreadsheet so i went to watch his
videos as well and this is very good
stuff this guy knows what he's talking
about if you want to have some fresh
news about amc you can find everything
that you're looking for there i'm sure
uh so once again thank you so much
brother for this and i wish you the best
and i see you on the moon so let's go
back here to
our uh stocks
some of you were making a list yesterday
bam bam bam
so i'm gonna have a look at that list so
first club i was in this in this one
okay so let's check clove n a k d okay
i'll just take the first one and you're
gonna see what i can do right now so
club okay bam
get synthetic short
here we're getting all the information
and if
i consider that this is high enough
okay so here we're having what
okay 1.4 is not big five percent of
synthetic short is not that small
okay
so to me this is not a very serious
candidate but let's say it is bam look
what i did move the stock to uh short
squeeze short list and i'm gonna keep
here all the stacks that to me you know
in terms of market cap in terms of
synthetic short of max synthetic shorter
so basically i can find the gamma here
the dtc i'm gonna keep all this
information i'm gonna build a solid uh
database guys that i'm gonna share with
you and i'm sure that very soon i'm
gonna be finding uh the next quizzes so
basically this is what i'm gonna try to
do and i have all the tools to do so so
i'm very excited to be doing this then
next one nakd let's see what we're
getting on this one
what i want to see is a big short and a
big dtc
okay this is what i'm looking for and a
small market cap
so here this one
i don't have information about this one
somehow then bb let's have a look at bb
bam
okay
wow this is high is it gonna come back
that's serious
market cap 6 billion
okay it's basically the volume is very
small here so the short is only 10 but
in terms of the volume traded it's a lot
okay i'm gonna add it to the shortlist
then one more i'm going to keep doing
this i'm just showing you guys how this
is working but i'm going to keep doing
this bias bsqr checked there is nothing
incredible a e i
i don't know this one
sometimes if it's not liquid enough i'm
not gonna get the right information here
okay the option market is like there is
nothing on this one so i guess i'll do
one more
n-a-o-v
okay last one but i'm gonna keep doing
this
on my side
there is nothing guys here there's
nothing you're giving me stocks where
there is nothing
i'm going to check
all right gizella
okay coming coming coming
no there is nothing here guys i'm not
gonna keep this one in the short list
it's very small okay so that's it for
today guys uh once again i'm gonna keep
doing this so i hope i managed to
explain how i find my targets how i
would uh be playing this move up we need
first to know the top of the third then
the bottom of the fourth and then it's
going to be very useful to predict the
top of the fifths so that's it for me i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
going to be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
show i'll see you guys